[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je je je je les adore ce genre d'état
visés c'est assez bouleversant et
j'adore ce mec super je pense que la
patience et les shoots importants dans
la vie j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qu'il a
inventé je suis un peu plus âgés que lui
je pense que je pense qu important de
gagner de l'argent que je fais je vais
pas d'intimité et que parler de comment
on arrive un moment dans sa vie à
comprendre plus important que l'argent
j'ai donc important que la réussite
qu'est le plus important que
le fait de
de ce pas 31.1 projet je pense que c'est
l'humanité je pense que c'est
c'est un pays je pense c'est une passion
je pense que les autres sont tous
importants j'ai commencé ma vie en un
peu comme comme vous pousse avec des
parents qui voulaient que mon père comme
chip quantité venu donc voulu tout
racheter moi j'étais nul en date donc
faire vivre à l'école donc carrément et
j'ai commencé à l'étudier
après le bac parce que justement on peut
perdre ce que tu dises espérons cherche
lors d'un comité donc je voulais faire
plaisir aux gens que j'aime et qui m'ont
tout donné j'ai pas vu les parents
auront pas voulu ils vont tous fait pas
il est dans la femme ont permis le très
pop c'est à dire clairement cremonese
mais s'est battu dans sa vie n'est pas
de donner ce qu'ils pouvaient voler et
donc j'ai fait déjà commencé dit âge
club et durant ses études y compris une
chose qui est très importante c'est
exactement ce que fait ce mec c'est la
passion est belge et ça me passionnait
pas jésus passa jeu
architecture c'était un truc que je
n'aime pas je le faisais pour faire
quelque chose mais je m'efface et donc
j'ai arrêté d'étudier et les parents à
accepter ça projet arrêté par les
allemands et j'ai fait un truc très lent
conforme que des personnalités de gagner
ce match j'étais stagiaire dans une
boutique où j'ai appris ce que le
premier
ça c'est quelque chose et culture en
allemagne et sur exister rester au maroc
à la bonne époque j'ai 34 ans je crois
que j'ai un peu près 14 ans de plus que
vous à l'époque segré on ne pouvait pas
vraiment encore facebook on n'avait pas
encore ses moyens de communication et l
idée pu mener pendant ces sept
ouvertures c'est too much pour la vision
donc si j'étais resté fort et je pense
que j'aurai subit la pression sociale
kiki obliger quelqu'un à aller dans le
sens de la société dans le sens de la
famille et par yves à 60 ans du festival
où tu dis est ce que ce que j'ai fait
c'est bien bas et parfois tu regrettes
aidez moi je connais des gens quand 60
ans ferait ce qu'ils ont vécu au milan
c'est très important
franchement comme à lens plus possible
avant de faire des choses que l'on veut
on
et en tout cas je pense n'ai jamais pris
part de faire ce que l'on aime entre
contre le sens et ça c'est très bon jeu
j'ai travaillé et donc je me suis auto
fort mais c'était la naissance du
youtube qu'on pouvait se forme
je me suis formé dans le poids d'une
chose le passionné à l'époque c'était la
jeune bella et super mauvais la petite
femme aux jeunes architectes donc ce que
je pouvais faire 50 la banque c'est
est-ce que ce passionné et internet et
ont eu disons les agences donc au début
faire un site internet salarié n'a pas
pu vous prenez cet intérêt à se sentir à
moi je les vends du amilo donc ce qui
revient à la même chose parce que
c'était la même chose la technicité
c'est juste devenir des vendeurs ça
secret je vais pas tissé par conformité
c'est important d'être techniquement
capables de fabriquer quelque chose et
de le vendre
pressé ses poils et en marquant sur la
carrière c'est autre chose
moi je ne suis pas fait mal
donc je peux pas vous dire est ce que
faire une carrière aux multinationales
c'est bienvenu j'ai vu mon père carrière
et je pense que c'est aussi bien de se
dire qu'on a un salaire de se dire qu'on
est retraite
de donner aussi de soi parce que dans
une entreprise on peut donner des autres
ok le terme shoah nathalie intrapreneurs
de cette entreprise dépend entreprend de
donner le mieux de soi même ou améliorer
cette structure coach pense que oui
effectivement ça va être intéressant de
funk à m moi j'ai quitté l'école pour
monter une structure jus de montée et
j'ai appris à vendre et puis j'ai monté
ma structure au début en france ça n'a
pas très bien marché et d'imprimantes
endemol ici en cherchant les clients et
j'ai eu des clients
j'ai gagné beaucoup d'argent pourquoi je
tenais par jour et je me suis arrivé à
85 salariés qu'elle ferait cavalier
c'est un million de dirhams de chasse
salariale à moi ça me dire que 15 du
mois vous ne dormez plus on les pensait
aux taxes et aux impôts au loyer au
téléphone que vous payez pour vous ça
et est resté les familles que vous
faites tout festive
donc il faut faire attention quand on
emploie des gens faut être capable de
tête sur ce niveau là de paiement de
devenir parce que les gens qui dépendent
de vous partout au salaire par rapport à
leur vie pendant cinq saisons
ça c'est très important donc moi j'ai
appris à 32 ans 31 ans 32 ans que
c'était pas ça s'est joué
j'aurais bien aimé faire en fin de
compte peut gagner un gros salaire de
gagner des choses matérielles sont très
importantes
oui c'est important de réussir
structurellement sa vie financièrement
mais elles étaient des aspects dans la
vie tu puis reprendre quand j'ai compris
de 31 ans qui sont je pense qu'ils ne
sont arrivés comme ça c'est que j'ai
beaucoup voyagé au maroc je suis rendu
compte que le maroc est un pays avec les
corps de six pouces sur la santé sur
l'éducation sur la société
les inégalités sociales énormes qui
désole les écoles et des ouvriers
agricoles et beaucoup changé
ce qui était important pour moi c'est
justement de faire ce que j'ai négocié
terrain et de le voir une autre famille
changer le cac bref je restructure et en
systèmes pour ne plus avoir à le vendre
aux entreprises
on parle de très bons titres à faire
quand on le vend à une entité est
aujourd'hui travailler avec des jeunes
artistes marocains du côté des futurs
qui s'intéresse aux jeunes artistes
marocains pour retrouver la scène et ça
c'est important parce que quand vous
faites quelque chose à la fin du trailer
tu donnes quelque chose à la société et
que tu sens que tu nommes c'est derrière
que tu dois sur un sur l'itinéraire très
rapide de temps et matériellement que
linkedin belge pas mon permis et match
de baseball pas tout seul adil échange
ale vision sur la vie échanges
c'est ça la maturité dans laquelle je
suis arrivé et elles doivent être
repensés j'ai adhéré ans justin jade
réponse est simple mais effectivement la
découverte d'un territoire
l'enrichissement de la société
l'évolution sur la santé etc et sont
tous donc j'ai relu structuré en
entreprise pour
d'abord pour prévenir cette crise de
moralité c'est je pense que la bâtisse
tout à l'heure par des attaques à 4 je
pense que c'est fini de son groupe était
encore long vers la future ou la
propriété j ai rien dit aujourd'hui
permet de ne plus avoir à dire aux îles
seychelles et d'un jour un gars c'est
sûr on peut aller au voyage en louant
une maison demain dans des pays où l'on
veut dans les eaux veux dans mon pays on
peut louer des voitures au centre du
helmand parfois j'ai pas de votre jeu de
circuits avec des sites est connu il y
avait eu bel accident ça va aller en
s'améliorant chose de la notion propre
idée d une voiture une maison et sa
proximité on va faire des choses qu'il
faut plus dans le partage et c7
c'est cette mentalité masse cet esprit
là je pense va se faire avancer un pays
comme le nôtre qui est cliquée dans des
dynamiques très complexe l'évolution ou
enfin pontife ou de l'entrepreneuriat je
pense à elle
c'est fait c'est vraiment cessé sa
clientèle et pour des jeunes que nous
qui sommes dans des gens qui font des
situations vivez vous savez pas encore
peuvent faire cela je pense qu'il ya ils
étaient 2 face à première c'est
d'intégrer des systèmes fallait
démissionner ce même centre du problème
qui peut vous apprendre un goût
structure un travail et à comment vous
organisez comment développer
comment arranger comment organiser comme
cadeau de vie etc
je pense que le tournant c'est plus
intense personnel c'est à dire qu' il va
se rejoindre vers votre passion mais
indépendamment de sa notion de rêve de
plaisir elle elle est importante parce
que vous n'aurez réaliste mais pas fait
ce que vous voulez c'est que je viens de
te dire que pourra par exemple tu dois
pas chanter parce qu'on éternue mais
parce que tu chantes tu vois pas gagner
d'argent loin je pense qu'il faut
obliger système a créé la billetterie a
obligé les gens à payer pour un musicien
et ne pas voir que des lycéens étrangers
voir les musiciens de sacs de faux pénis
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les projets
d'avenir d'un pays comme le maroc c'est
se reconcentrer sur une somme
identitairement c'est qu'ils sont les
artistes qui sont les personnes les
kilos qui me représente aux architectes
aux artistes aux développeurs ça et vous
à travers le pays
l'économie fait l'ensemble est ce que
vous faites est excellent et on devait
être service de ces gens qui ont vendu
techniquement et socialement pour le
faire les aider à arriver à leurs fins
winning sales et je pense moins à la
conclusion de tout ça c'est que leur gré
n'a jamais émis à partir du moment où on
le définit où le jeu est on est on est
on veut arriver et je pense que la
dynamique argent finance development et
c est important mais n'est pas le coeur
d'une fille n est pas le coeur d'une
pensée et elle elle peut créer une
source du bonheur dans un certain sens
si vous n'êtes pas abouti dans votre
assiette de foie
et si vous vous posez des pas importants
de c'est vraiment arrivé à s'aimer
soi-même peu de s'accepter
est-ce qu'on est noirs dans le chant du
gros mais et c'est là je trouve qu'il
faut s'aimer et on le voit aujourd'hui
que ce qui compte c'est de s'accepter
soi-même pour être meilleur on s'est
vraiment être plus on m'a dit
aujourd'hui à 34 ans j'ai deux enfants
je pense que je n'ai jamais été aussi
heureux j'ai jamais eu aussi peu
d'argent mais je suis
[Applaudissements]